好
大家晚上好
声音视频正常的话
请扣个6
等一下
你不要问我了
我之前都已经跟大家说过了
上周
今天
都有说
那么你们现在很关心的两个问题是
行情能走到哪里去
不知道
懂了吗
那个三万亿还没下来呢
是吗
我也不知道
没有经历过
对不对
那么昨天跟大家讲了这个DC的策略
这唐前通道的策略
大家有没有回去
这个自己复盘看了一下
有没有
有复盘的请在屏幕上打个9啊
这是我昨天教你们的方法
你有去仔细去对照过的啊
比如在黄金啊
在原油上面啊
自己去找过的啊
你们感觉怎么样
童话里都是骗人的啊
好
之前有人跟我说
不要做逆时交易
对吧
骂了个把子啊
结果呢
每次呢
我又顺势吧
顺在什么地板上
对不对
当别人在招拐点的时候
你还在追空
好
结果什么
上来了
对不对
我说过啊
市场当中没有绝对的多和空
现在的多头以后就是潜在的空头它是互相转换的明白了吧关键就是看这个转换是先知先觉的转换
还是后知后觉
还是什么
不知不觉
懂了吗
那么昨天我们的原理
是用什么原理
大家应该知道的
用的就是什么
人性
对吧
用的是人性
那么顺势策略跟这个反转策略
他们的区别在哪里
我今天跟大家阐述一下
好吧
首先顺势策略
比如说我今天给的黄金和原油
它是属于什么策略
小时级别的
就是日内级别的什么顺势
对吧
你没看到我这两天群里面打的都是突破的策略吗
是不是这样
今天在群里面下
上午的时候跟大家发的
对吧
中午我说下午一点钟
如果突破你就做多
那么突破的策略有一个问题
是什么
他胜率不高
你理解吗
胜率不高的
因为你做顺势吗
突破的吗
因为有50%的几率
你能吃到假突破
对不对
这是第一个问题
第二个问题
他的好处是什么呢
大段小赔
顺势的策略
那么拐点
抓反转
它的胜率很高
但是
如果按照昨天
唐签通道的这个指引的话
我们可以看到
它什么
盈亏比是不及顺势的
因为你自己给自己设了一个限定
对吧
我们比如说
当你举个例子
比如说黄金
你自己给他设定了一个
人为设定了一个什么
界限对吧
来看啊
那么你看一下
我们如果用这个策略做的话
是不是打到上轨
我们就要平仓了
因为我们抓的是反转这一波嘛
对不对
打到上轨我就要走
看到了吧
这啊
但是有个问题
你跑了之后
行情可能继续是吗
延伸
对不对
继续再往上延伸
懂吗
就是他到了这个点
按照理论上
我们应该要止盈
他不停下来继续涨那么这个时候你会出现问题就是什么你出来了之后怎么还在涨那么就有可能要逼着你再去做什么
再去做个做根式
懂了没有
但是顺势的话什么概念是
拿到它不能拿为止
对不对一直拿着
只要这个趋势还在我就一直拿着
所以他理论上来说顺势的这个盈利是无限大的
但是你抓拐点
你的盈利是可预计的
可预知的
为什么TK老师的这个
他的策略都是有明确的指引位置
TP1 TPR TP3
记住了没有
因为他这个系统属于什么系统
反转系统
所以胜率很高
但是赚大钱
我指的大钱你们懂吗
赚大钱往往是没有TP
才能赚大钱
就是说有心
有心灾速竖不开
无心插流流成音
明白这个意思的
打个意
我们今天晚上来直播的原理
不然直播的原因是
跟大家探讨交易
不是来跟我去争论多还是空
对吧
如果你待会儿听得不顺眼
我要把交隔单贴出来
那没有意义的
对不对
我赚的再多是我的
跟你没有关系
你就是涂个嘴巴快乐
对吧
赚予亏你自己心里有数
对不对
咱们都要成熟
对吧
我们作为一个交易者
我们要有交易者的素养
那说是不是
无论你的体系如何
你的交易理念是怎么样子的
归根到底
我们在干的是同一件事情
都是在做交易
就是从这一点
我们是一个战壕里的人
对吧
是不是
我们讲道理
咱们是P的战友
人家以前说
一起扛过墙
一起瓢过什么
对吧
我们再加一个
一起做过交易
是不是
这个
道理是一样的
明白了吧
好
那么这个周线图
大家应该都了解什么意思的
对吧
昨天跟大家说过了
周先生说
周先生图像是很明显的对不对明显吧那你看BK就是BaseK基准点高点出来了吧
我们现在就是拐点
那么如果你是按照
你是按照周线图做的时候
应该是哪里指引
你们来告诉我
按照周线级别去做的话
是哪里指引呢
是周线的上轨对吧
那么现在我们已知的上轨的点位
是在哪里啊
是在1560附近
对不对
但是呢
那谁的时间飘移
他会往下走
因为他是置后余价格的
对吧
他会往下
可能就最后的这个白线
到碰到收盘价的时候
他不是这个位置
但是你现在瞄的话
就是瞄这个位置的
所以他这个地方是明确的
那么你用天图也是很明确的
那就是这个位置
有可能今天晚上就能到
对吧
有可能明天
看到了吧
就是说你去抓这个位置
打到突破上轨的时候
按照反转的这个系统
你就要止盈了
那你说我能不能不跑
对吧
我们讲一个这个问题
我能不能不止盈啊
能不能
可以不止盈吗
当然可以
为什么
那你这样吗
你拐点抓到了之后呢
你平一半行不行
那今天跟大家说
那我就假设我现在有多单
下面开上来的
到这我先平一半
对不对
还有一半我拉一个什么跟踪
如果说回来了
那就赚点点钱
如果他继续往上走
我就不动了
这样进口攻退口守
有可能你能吃到
就是抓拐点以外的收益
对不对
懂了吧
那你昨天有人跟我留言说
那我到了这
他如果继续涨的话
那我不是错过了吗
那你今天解决方案就是这个
留一半便宜一半吗
简单吧
会了吧
按照我的个性
如果像这种级别的拐点
那么我听不上我是不出去的
懂了没有
我是不走的
知道吧
因为就是说
我我去抓管点的目的是为了什么
为了顺势
去持仓的
我的所有的目标
只有一件事情
就是让我持仓
不是让我去平仓
而是持仓
也就是说我
就是说
我的交易思想是什么
只有持仓
我的仓位乘以时间
我才能抓到
能够让我挥霍的什么
钱
我不想每天
为了那个几千美金
在那边晃来晃去
浪费时间
头发都掉了
甚至为别人打工
我不想做一个什么
打工的人
我想当老板
所以这归根到底哪里出问题
大家想一想
这是思想的问题
理念的问题
对不对
我们很多时候在
其实大部分人
自知不见的去研究
怎么去入场
怎么去进场
对吧
很多人在找
什么点位进场好
什么位置进场好
他在研究这个
没有花时间
在研究怎么去持仓
懂了
你去看一下
你停在开仓点上的时间
思考的时间多
还是在持仓的上面
思考时间多
90%的人在研究
怎么进场的问题
10%的人
9%的人在研究
怎么出场的问题
还有1%的人在研究
怎么持仓的问题
同意的打个1
大部分人
他学这个学那个学这个
就想找到所谓精确的什么
买入点位
对不对
好
有时候你真的买到了很好的位置
确实回头看
那个位置真的超好超好的
你们很多人是经历过超好点位
经常的
对不对
但是你们看一下
你们大概只吃了整波
行情的10%都不到
然后就
后面又打回原形了
因为你没有这种经历
没有这种经验
没有体会过
什么叫赚钱
那个叫那种赚钱
你没有体会过
对不对
这一条红沟
需要自己去突破
没有人能够帮你懂了吗有时候有些人呢他看别人这么做了他心里有意识的他知道了有些人就是即便给他看了
他也还是不明白的
一定是要自己经历过
很长时间的这个沉淀
或者说历练啊
或者说整个在教训当中
他突然有一天他想明白了
所以我讲的东西
现在有很多人可能听不懂
没有关系
落干年之后
落干人之后你会明白的
懂了吗
你一定会明白的
只是时间还没有到而已
那么到那个时候
你再想起我现在
似曾
就是很久很久以前有这么一个人
没事跟傻子一样
天天给我们做直播
把啥都不要的
给我们讲这些东西
当时我觉得他是个傻子
那个时候
你等你到那个时候悟到的时候
你会发现我自己才是个傻子
我现在跟你们讲的东西
都是讲的是实话
因为我就是这么过来的
懂了吗
经历过了
所以我跟你去说
当然用语言表达的可能
只能表达十分之一
因为还有很多东西是说不出来的
无法用文字去表达的
无法用语言去表达的
能懂吗
这一步你们自己要去
就是说
我否认啊
就是交易这个东西
不是所有人都适合
对不
但是你说我现在已经发愿了啊
我一定要把交易做好
交易就是我终身的这个什么追求啊
我一定要在交易市场能够什么成功
你发这个愿是好的
对不对
每个人都希望自己把交易做好
没问题
是别忘了
能够逆天改命的
其实是寥寥无几的
这个现实你要接受
对不对
你说那我成神成仙
我做不到
我起码来个延年益寿吧
长生不了我不行
那我延年益寿总行吧
延年益寿做不到
我身体健康
我寿终正寝总行吗
那不要得什么病就行了吗
那你连寿终正寝都做不到那怎么办那就给求个好死那不要横实街头不要什么恨祸对不对我就我已经讲到
讲到这个层次了
你们要自己听得懂
好吧
OK
今天
我再给你们
教一个手法
是来自于机构的
好吧
我估计
我讲了
你们99%左右的人
也没有听过
因为我说过
这个世界上
你能够轻易找到的东西
是人家故意要放给你的
懂了吗
我讲的东西都很简单
就讲这个东西
其实几分钟都能讲完的
但是中间的道理
你要明白
对不对
老师是在劝退我吗
是的
你但凡有自知之明
如果你想好好过日子
想生活求个太平安稳的
那么你劝退
这是比较好的
知道了吧
你不听我的也没关系
反正到时候你就知道
之前有个人跟我说过
让我不要做
这个我没有听
由于自己的这个
怎么说
修行不道
然后
种了很多因
那么这个果你给自己承受的
好吧
好今天跟大家再讲这个新的策略
或者说技巧
OK
等一下
今天我们用的方法是
熬顶的方法
或者说做空的方法
昨天讲的是做多的对吧
今天我们讲做空的方法
好不好
鲜花给一波
没有鲜花打个888也行
金不能白取
怎么
好的今天我们所需要用到的东西连指标都没了昨天我们还用到唐奇岸通道
今天咱们没了
好吧
现在我先画一个模块
大家来跟上我的节奏
先看一下
看一下
这个是什么
假突破或者说2B
对吗
那平时我们要找做空的
第一个信号
是不是要符合这样的状态
之后再展开所谓的双顶结构
或者是头肩
或者是其他的形态
他肯定要走这个结构出来
对吧
这是他第一步
就是他要形成下跌趋势
他肯定是打星高之后
这不打不了星高之后
再打星低下去吗
同意吧
就所有的下跌趋势
都要经历过这个过程
对不对
就先
先再创一个星高
然后下来上不去了
上不去之后
拐头什么
向下
所以这个位置
那么你说
那我怎么知道
他后面会不会跌
那么今天我们就讲什么
讲信号的问题
好的
那么大家其实可以把我今天讲的内容
跟TK老师的CB
DB
IB
结合起来
六根线
帮你抓到一个顶部
或者说得到一个比较好的开工位置
我们只需要用到六根K线就可以
这会连指标都不要了
好吧
你说
怎么说啊怎么叫六根 k 线
你看啊
我现在画六根 k 线给你们看一下
随便画啊
几个了五个了对吧
好
前面我就随便画一画啊
可能是这样一个东西
对吧按照常理说呢我们要干嘛
要注意这个点
对不对
下去了
对吧
来看一下
哪根线开空
来你们选一下
这张图上
你们如果是你们
你们会在哪个点去做空它
选一下
对
我们把它标记一下吧
哎不对
从这边开始数啊
从左往右数吧
对吧
1234567890啊
这有10个
第7个
那就是这里
对吧
从左到右第七个
1234567
这里
好
我现在把颜色加一下
今天呢
我把这个东西给老农了
我让他写一个这个
可视化的
不知道他有没有空
对吧
这个画图其实也没有什么意义了
我直接给你们报答案吧
好吧
我直接报答案了啊
我也不要去画多了泪
我现在没鼠标啊
我现在用的是键盘
电脑上的那个触摸的那个鼠标
好吧
我现在来标记给你们看一下
好了
这个左边我把它擦掉
右边我把它擦掉
我就留六根线
零在这
你先把这个图大概先心里面记一下
就是有这么一个形态在能看到吧好的这边给大家注意一下
第四根K线
你要注意
画的不是很精确
你就大概的意思
懂了吗
这里往下跌跌跌跌跌
注意看啊
第四根的低点在这里
对不对
好
那么注意
第四根必须是最低点
四的低点要比五
要比三
要比二
要低
它是最低的那根线
这一步能等到打个E
必须是最低
3要比他
3号线2号线5号线都要比他高
低点要比他高
收盘价无所谓
关键是低点
好
然后这根线
这个必须是阳线
一号线必须是阳线
来的
它可以打新高
也可以不打新高
这个高度无所谓
这根线必须是阳线
懂了吗
二号线无所谓
阴和阳都可以
二号线可以阴也可以阳
懂了吧
但是一号线必须是阳线
自己记一下
好
这根也是阳线吧
那么这根线
做什么
做空
能理解吧
这根线做空
有人说不对啊这不是突破吗这不是突破吗对吧这不是明显创新高了吗怎么可以做空呢我前面说过了
机构就是这么杀人的
来能够理解再打个料
它是反转系统
然后大概率就会这么走
你们去看啊
每次他要跌之前
就一个行情他要下跌之前
他会干什么
你们仔细去看一下
他有时候耍流氓是怎么耍的
他先往上勾一勾
然后再猛摔
吃过这种亏的人
屏幕上打个二
他每次要跌之前
他总会会先往上拉一下
对吧
有吧
为什么呢
这个动作表示什么意思
有人说吸引跟风盘吗
对吧
骗一下多头啊
实际上不是
这根线的意义就是试探
就是说他花很小的钱
去试一下这个空头
他不是试多头
他是试空头
就是说我突然之间一个大单往上一拉
然后我就不管了
我看这个价格多少时间能够往下回来
如果他回的速度很快就说明
我后面启动这个空投行情
我可以不发
不就是不费什么力气
就就会有空空投去跟随我
实际上他这个地方是一个试仓的动作
试的并不是多
而是空
往往有时候数据公布之前
他会这么走的
你们注意看啊
重大的这个消息
或者说经济市经济这个报告
对吧
或者什么飞龙什么
他往往会这样先来一下
啊
长的时候也是这样的
他长的时候是反过来的
他他妈先往下跌一下
再上去
有没有
他要涨之前
他先给你跌一下
他要跌之前先给你拉一下
这是机构的一些什么手法
那么不明真相的人呢
这个地方就可能去追多
那么一追进去就完了
懂了吗
但是你要符合这个形态
符合这个形态
你们以后就记住了
懂了吧
从这根突破的往前看
这根线必须是阳线
一号线必须是阳线懂了这个东西在任何洲际上都可以当然你在大周期上看到这个那更更要命一点对不对他所蕴含的能量更大一点
然后呢
其实就很简单了啊
我们找找个例子呗
好吧
我们找个例子呗
啊
我们来看一下好吧
其实你们有时候呢
你们自己去去翻一翻啊
也能够翻得到的
对吧
它不是所谓的底分形
它跟底分形没关系
它是一种手法
懂了吗
就是有时候
它假突破上去之后
它会玩什么
玩阴的
一般就是这种情况
就是你看它创新高了
就说你要小心
尤其是你看
你要看四号线
看这个
如果这根线
它不是最低点的
没事
懂了吗
这根线
它不是最低点的
有时候还能说说
可能还能再冲一冲
如果是符合这个形态的
那你就要当心了
懂了没有
那么其实这个等于是什么
是左侧进场
懂了没有
它实质上是一种左侧进场的
这个感觉
对吧
左侧进的
就是什么意思
你并没有看到它往下就跌了
你再进去
而是你看到它长的时候进去
懂了吗
一般情况是等他什么
快收线的时候
你看好
这根阳线很扎实
那么正常情况下
信号就是说
按照其他系统的话
应该是给出多头进场信号
对吧
那么恰恰就在这个时间
那你们都最多了
结果PRG收割
懂了吧
那么这种
这种案例在什么地方比较多
知不知道
就像这种像这种图形
在什么地方会比较多一点
商品上
股票上
懂了
商品和股票上特别多
特别特别多
尤其是A股
你就知道了
对吧
A股的股民经常是这样被干死的
比如说这一天涨了8%
甚至涨停板
他就在涨停板出货了
对吧
做空了
实际上他是一种
怎么说呢
就是派发的派发之前的一种行为
懂了吧就主力想
把手上的这个筹码抛出去他应该怎么办
一般说是这么干的啊
就是说我们举个例子啊
当然这个不是我说的那种情况啊
看到了没有
打新高了吧
突破了吧
看到没有
然后你说这根线不算
那再来一个
这根线算不算通过
跳空高开
创历史新高
对吧
很棒
棒棒两个掌停板
开心了
之后你会更开心
他要跌之前他干嘛
他这样来一下
防不胜防吗
怎么可以这么干
对吧
他就是这么玩的
好吧
那么今天呢
呃
你待会也要去做功课啊
要去复盘看一下
去找一下这样的形态
懂了吗
有时候小时都会出来
有时候四小时都会出来
有时候天都上会出来
明白了吧
没听明白
你把这个图再拿一下
你再仔细仔细观察
懂了
能观察吧
有人给我找到了
对吧
北大农
这个东西呢
你要把它变成记
它是一种肌肉器
理解了吧
你说它在哪里
哪一波
这里对吧
是不是这里
这里不对
你看
这个位置
这根线
你懂吗
这根线比较长
对不对
这个低点要比这个低点要高
就这个低点往下来就对了
明白我意思了吧
那我给你举个例子
来来来看好了
我现在画图
你把这里挡掉懂了吧
这就OK了
这就对了
注意看
你把它拉过来
这个线是不是最低点
0 1 2 3 4 5 3 2都比4要高
那么1是阳线
那么这一天你就做空
用花刷一波
看明白了吗
哪几个关键你要注意
一个是这根线
还有一个是这根线
一线和四线最重要
中间都是过渡
然后就等它上来
然后你就在这个位置开空
收盘架
开一个空
然后他就滚下去了
主题就是这么玩的
看到了没
回来打个一
那么手法恶劣不还好吧
这还不是最恶劣的
就他要跌之前
他会给你先搞一波
懂了吧
他会先给你来一下
那么你再看这一波行情
来来看
这边是不是
大家仔细看一下
看好了
先跌的对吧
对吗
别急
这里不符合
我们再看一下
下一根线
这里符合了吧
4的低点比5
都要低
是阳线
这根线是零对吧
那么你就在这根线做空
然后再见
看到了吧
滚
再见了
懂了吧
那你按照这个手法做
你能看出来了
看到没有
所以要观察
懂吧
哪里打新高了
这不是打新高了吗这不是超过五天之前的那个最高价格了吗懂了吗他的动作是什么
你要看啊
他动作是这个样子
仔细看一下
那他这样
先下
再上去
下的旁边那根线往下抖
然后他上去的时候也是这样
他会比那个五号线要高
当然你可以碰到这个更大的轴旗上
你比如说在周线图上找找看
也有的呀
周线图上也有的
给你找一个看看啊
就你要会卡位置
你就知道了
对吧
4的低点
小于5
小于3
小于2
1是阳线
那么在0的收盘价做空
下去
这里是不是打新高的
好
那么你正常情况下
一看要长得挺好的
我做个多去吧
再见
学会了吧
别人出货了呀
不玩了呀
看到了没有
就是个道理
好了
学会就行了
然后呢
你把这个图形导过来用呢
就是
不管才用的
知道了
有人说
现在的金子符合这个手法
我们来看一下
周先生是什么
你说哪里
现在吗
现在有吗
大家告诉我
现在黄金有吗
有没有
你现在不这周线吗有没有是吧不是你怎么看出来是有的呢我就没搞懂了啊
我没看到
对吧
哎
所以我也不知道他
他是怎么想的啊
尽力了
对吧
我们尽力了啊
嘿嘿
对不对
好吧没有
没有的话就不用管它了
那么这个图
它是一种识别模式
其实也很简单
对吧
简单吧
没有
就留根线就可以了
那么以后你碰到了之后呢
你就知道
这个地方好像有问题
那么哪怕你不去做那个零号线的空单
那么这个多你是不是要谨慎一点
明白了吗
来明白了打个一啊
下次你哪怕你不做空
你想做多的时候你瞄一眼吧
前面五根线的结构是什么样子的
对吧
那其实从技术的角度来看
它特别清晰嘛
就是一个向上的V
所谓的一个V
很有诱惑性
对吧
好
这个图导过来
就是抓那个多头的
做多的那个方法
懂得没有
那做多的方法
我也给大家画一下
正好和这个图导过来的
明白了
你把这图导过来就知道了
我也不画了
我准备这就是简单一点
垂直旋转一下
懂得没有
颜色你改一改就行了
颜色你把它改一下
我就偷懒了
我就不重新画了
就这样
懂吗
一号线
不是
这个一号线必须是什么
阴线
然后这里的四号线
必须是最高点
懂了没有
然后一号线最好是
不是最好
就是一定是要阴线
然后零线
做多
明显做多
往往你会开在一个很极限的位置上
对吧
懂得没有
那么这个方法需不需要带止损呢
当然需要带止损
有一个前提就是
止损是怎么去挂的问题
对吧
现在我们讲一下
因为你现在抓的是反转系统
对不对
比如说我们把这个前面那个
做空的这个原理
那么你就其实就可以放在四号点上
你的止损位置就放在四号点上
做空的
不是说错了
反过来
再把它调回来
你看
你在这里开的这个止损
放哪里
就放在这个高点上面
零号线的高点上
那么上移多少呢
你就以它的最高价
上幅一个
上幅一到两个价格就可以了
不用设太多
因为这个止损
就是非常非常小的止损
不用带很大的
你以黄金为例
就是比如说黄金
你看到这个信号的出来了
对吧
那么这一天临近收盘了
那么你就在今天的最高点上
上幅多少
三到五美金就可以了
不用拉什么十美金
二十美金不用的
因为他这个策略的效果就是
很小的资产
因为你抓他是反转
你不像你做趋势
你手前低的那种
那个不是懂了吗
就他这个策略是可以带很小的资产
而且是已经迎上去干的
你没发现吗
反人性的
所以这里的容错的距离
不会给你太多的
以黄金就最多就五美元
成就成不成拉倒
弄了打个六
那么做做多也是一个道理
这颗图导过来看
你就把资本带在这个零号线往下
比如说这里黄金为例啊
就这个低点往下五美元
你如果明天继续往下跌破
我就什么再见
不玩了
哎你让我抓到了那就
懂了吗
那么这里往上反的第一目标位在哪里
应该都清楚了吧
第一目标位就是之前的这个四号点的高点
就是破心高
就是这
就打到这你要做一个标记
这边要要做一个什么
这个标识
就打到这你可以检查或者指引掉
明白了吧
那么这个图导过来也是一样的
你做空的话
你就你在上面开空的
对吧
你就这个零号线开空
你的第一指引位置就是四号线的地点
一般来说打到这都会有支撑至于原因你们懂的呀对吧打到这会停一停有时候他会在这地方稍微停顿一下
那么碰到这种很强
比如他已经长了很多了
已经长得很好
翻了好长时间了
长了好长好长时间的时候
那么他幅度可能会大一点
懂了没有
这个点一突
那么其实上
我再跟你们解释一下
每一个问题啊
这个转折你抓到了之后
那么这个
这个边
这个底边被击穿了
意味着另外一个东西出来
趋势就有可能形成了
对不对
啊
你看一下啊
对吧
有可能就
他这个趋势就可能要形成
为什么
破前提了
懂不懂我意思
你这个时候呢
你后续的这个跟踪
就不能拿这个系统来了
或许的更多的转
你要转到什么
趋势系统上
对吧
你走到这个位置
是不是从图形上来看
已经跌破前期的这个底边了
这个有可能要转空了
对不对
这个时候你应该用什么策略
顺势策略
就结合上顺势策略就可以
明白了吧
如果未来展开
那么你的移动止损挂在哪里
就挂在四号点这里
你把你的移动止损
往下拉就行了
就拉到这里
后面
做去世的方法
就是尺烫不动
你要是牛逼
你回来
我全部只赢掉
我不玩了
懂了吧
你如果能反上来
打掉我的什么跟踪
我就这波就算我结束了
如果你不回到这个点上
我拿到你天荒地老为止
你就要给有这个气魄
要不然我花这么多时间
抓这个拐点
有毛病啊
懂了没有
就是再怎么地横数
我就赚这一波我是吃定了
对吧
那么后面能不能继续往下跌
不知道看命的
老天爷说你最近比较穷
多给你点钱
那就可能再多走几根线
对不对
继续往下走去试就好了
好吧
所以今天我们就是说
利用六根K线去抓什么
抓拐点的方法
懂了没有
当然这个方法属于什么
属于短线
还是说句话
就是虽然我们用的是天图
这个信号是用在天图上的
那实质上也是短线懂了没有但是呢它可以帮助你们建立什么优势至于你能不能跳过去
就是说从抓拐点
当反弹
当反转
当反弹去做
然后后面是能不能切换到趋势上
这就要考验大家自己了
就是我把你带到这一步
后面你能走多远
我也不知道
我现在只是把技巧告诉你们
懂了吗
那么一般我自己做的时候
我会这么干
我先讲的比较细
是看我的手法怎么做的
我这个地方
是以反转的心态
拐点的心态去抓这个什么
极限位置
对吧
用很小的子损
我试一下行不行
当这个低点
四号点如果被带量突破
就成长量能够配合上
我会在这个点跌破的时候
我会选择
顺势加码的
而且我加码的方式
你们不理解
我是这么加的
比如说这个位置
我开一手对吧
这个点我就可能开两手
或者三手了
放量下去
懂了没
然后我就会把我
开一手的这些盈利
当做我这边开两手
三手的止损去用
能不能理解
那么于是乎
我这个拐点也就不存在了
在我心里面没有这个拐点的问题了
后面就是趋势能不能展开的问题
中间你看它会有连接
并不是说一个系统用到死
中间会有连接
你怎么去切换
对吧
比如你上了高速公路
前面看到一个这个这个电子探头
那么你主动的就会把油门松开
把车速控制在100以内
对不对
好了
这时候你看一下GPS
前方两公里
五公里之内都没有探头的
这时候你会加速
你开120去了
甚至140
是不是这样
走走停停
你会有个切换的这个节奏吗
好吧
跟大家分享一下
有会了吧没有M这里面没有M这个是后面走出来你才看到M的我现在
我现在只是说到这儿
后面你联想到什么
我不知道
对不对
也跟我没什么关系
其实我今天讲的
讲的主要内容
不是说讲后面的问题
主要是讲前面的问题
我只讲
我只负责讲到这儿
后面怎么走
我也不知道
你自己看吧
懂了没有
就这里一坨不知道的
后面一坨需要你们自己去悟
就到这就行了
懂了吧
这个图你理解就可以了
一和四的问题
一必须是什么
哪样的
四必须是哪样的
懂了吧
这两个连一和四是连接
5320是什么
是过程
零是启动
那么我说过了
这个盈亏比是很高的
对吧
就是你不是找入场位置吗
什么盈亏比最划算
就是这种
就是你可以带很小的资算
那么如果说第二天又创新高了呢
你就不玩了呀
对吧
又来一根阳线
那你就损失就
也就这么点
但是你要跌到这个位置的话
你先算一下盈亏比再说
懂了
你看啊
这是我的开仓点
我的资算可能在这里
我的指引
在下面
我的资算
这么点
看懂了打个6
这个盈亏比是非常高的
非常高的盈亏比
但是它是反人性的
它是逆势的
OK
至于它后面展开
往下破位
那是顺势的问题
今天不在我们讨论的范畴
好吧
随风而动
问个问题
你问吧
说
林浩显
对
怎么了
林浩线怎么了
林浩线可以是阳线
也可以是十字星
懂了吧
我懂你意思
就是说盘中
盘中它是阳线
然后收盘又变成这个样子
对吧
收成这种
一根上引线的
这种情况
是不是
假设啊
我现在举个例子
是不是这样
对不对
那它也是零
懂了没
也是零号线
零号线就是要做空的
那么你们可能认为
拼罢出来了
不管它
但是这个止损就不一样了
如果是这种情况碰到长丁怎么办
你的止损就是设定在长丁到收到开盘
如果是阳线
就是长丁的最高点到收盘价的二分之一位置
在这个地方设止损
如果是阴线
就是长丁到它的开盘价设止损
有时候呢
比如说他这个地方
你开进去之后
他不是马上跌的
他这个地方再来
再来给你来一次
再去破一个小新高
然后盘中再击穿下来回来
就是这种情况
就是他
比如说这是零号点
对吧
零号线
他是先跌一下
然后再上来
轻轻的去摸一下
就比这个高点
再高一点点的地方
然后他就马上就回来了
对
也会出现这种扫损的情况
懂了没有
有的
这种几率有的
懂吧
有的
那么就关键是
看你的盈亏比怎么去设定了
那么我这边有个方法
跟你们说一下
好不好
因为我说
比如说前面我举的例子
是黄金带五美金
实质上你们可以这么去估算
你可以算一下
就是这个区域有多少和宽
这个区间有多少和宽
什么叫和宽
就是空间的大小
比如说这个高点
到了这个低点可能30美金
假设啊
假设是30美金
那么你根据你已知的利润空间
然后去除以一个倍数
就得出你的止损的据兼具了
懂得没有
比如说你要是5比1的话
你就除以6
你就止损就带6美金就可以
那么你的盈亏比是5比1
理解来打个1
我们至少要保证5比1的盈亏比那么你就事故于这个间距是多少吗决定吗对不对懂了吗
那么如果说他这里是20
这个空间只有20美金
那么按照1比5的算
那么我的止损就带4美金就可以了
并不是固定值
那么你可以参考前期的这个什么
Ranger到底有多大的什么高度
然后通过这个高度呢
给他
我们说了5比1的盈亏比
那么你就画五根线
然后推导上去就知道了
取一格
就是你的
这根K线的开仓价
最高价往上浮动
这个X
这个X是你们自己要去算的
当然这个很简单
你小学数学的
数学毕业的
你就能算出来
对不对
这个点值是多少
比如说外汇
这里可能是500个点
那么你的止损就是
这根线最高点加100个点
加100个点就是你的止损
好吧
就是止损的
就关键还是你止损
怎么去调教的问题
因为我们做了
做这个动作是为了高音辉比
懂了吧
那么如果这个
就是你去看啊
如果说发生这种现象的时候
发生这种现象的时候
你要还有一个关键的地方
你要注意的是哪里
知不知道
还有一个问题
除了止损设定以外
你就要看盘中的问题
我是盘中进去呢
还是等收盘的快收盘的时候
还是第二天次日进场
现在要考考你们啊
那什么时间进去比较好
是盘中
让它拉上去我就进空
收盘的时候
我进空
还是第二天开盘以后
我再进口
以收盘下进去
对不对
有人选收盘下进
还有呢
盘中进吗
盘中要不要进
其实这三种都可以
我说实话
这三种都可以
关键问题
我们说过
我们不要把一个东西定得很死
这样就失去它的什么主观能动性了对不对那么什么情况下面我们当天就进去不用等收盘什么时候我们要快到收盘的时候进去
什么时候我们第二天再进去
想一想
这个地方他会分什么
分条件的
所以我把条件的内容
跟大家说一说
懂了吧
有条件的啊
比如说我们要选择在盘中进
他有一个前提
有个前提
就什么时候盘中可以去追
不是去追
去拦截做这个空
那就是要利用到日内的技术
你必须找到
这是多头的这个高潮放浪点
如果没有多头高潮的放浪点
盘中是不可以进的
我之前就讲VSA的时候
清楚了没有
就是当天日内
他必须见到什么
多头的高潮量出来
没有高潮量
盘中是不进的
就临近收盘的时候
或者次日进
这个条件记住了吗
就是日内当中
我们把它切到
比如说这个是日线图的
你切到小视图上去看
它必须完成
多头的高潮量堆出来
盘中就可以进
如果没有这个多头高潮
那么就得收盘
或者第二天开盘
以后
对吧
这个
关键就是看放明放亮嘛
就这么简单
日内
他就没有放到过多头
多头的高潮上出来
就是这个标准
有的话盘东就可以进
没有的话
那就老老实实等他快收盘的时候
或者早上早点起来
对不对
那么止损都是一样的
好吧
今天这个就算讲完了
学会了吧
它某种意义上来说也是个反转系统
六线转折
见零出手
好吧
亮今天讲不了了
可以往前看一下我过去过往的这个视频
TK老师的这个网页上面应该都有
量肯定讲不完那讲量要讲很长时间好吧吧现在还有什么问题要问的黄金日线是不是这个形态
你觉得是吗
你自己看呀
对不对
那你今天刚学的
你觉得你觉得
大家觉得是不是是不是
你们觉得是吗
你数吗
假设现在是零
零一二三
你不用数了
这根线就不对嘛
如果这里是零的话
这根线应该什么颜色
来说
这根线如果是零
就今天这根线是零
那么一号线应该是什么颜色
对了红色
那就不用不合
滚蛋
对吧
它是绿的
对不对
它就不对了
知道了吧
没有
没有的
好吧
还有问题没有
还有什么想问的
有点困难啊
阳线啊
一号线你做空
它必须是阳线
你要做多
一号线必须是阴线
原油今天大招了
漂亮
今天中午给的对吧
今天我记得是中午吧
对不对
我说下午一点钟以后突破
这边高点
坐坐原油去
然后我也不知道今天船又堵了
跟我没关系
不是我干的
好吧
这个船不是我堵的
苏伊士运河那边
不是跟我没关系的
对吧
以后还可以拿一会
因为他那个周线上
看到那个
昨天我们学过的
那个DC策略
对吧
他是有的
他是有信号的
好了
这个所有周期都能用吗
理论上是的
好吧
可是你用一分钟
你想想吧
你是嫌人手续费太便宜了
对吧
你就一分钟了
对不对
最近猪瘟
猪瘟的话疫苗呀
动物疫苗
你们今天没有看那个
国内农产品吧
来给大家看一下
等一等啊
看一下农产品的走势
生猪
猪呢在这啊
来看一下国内的深猪价格
看到了吧
看到了没有
我也拍下去了
你等闹猪瘟呢
就这个走势嘛
懂了吗
就这个
OK
我们把深猪的这个指数给大家调出来
因为你们现在看到这主力回约
这边看上去有点
看不清楚
我们把指数调出来
你不是闹非洲猪瘟吗
那你就只就看猪肉这个植树吗
对不对
等一下啊
躺哪去了
诶猪呢
伸出指数
还是这个
你看这个就好一点
看得清楚一点
但是它上市的时候
最高的话是多少钱
看一下
三万多
看到没有
三万多块钱
我们现在是一
两万六
对吧
然后在去年的这个
看时间啊
去年的十月
是十月吧
看下时间啊
去年十月份回上来之后见顶的嘛
然后现在一直在点
看到了没猪肉啊
那猪肉价格为什么点呢
两个方面原因
第一个
那么猪肉去年太贵了
在国家现在就是枪打抽头鸟
老百姓说猪肉太贵吃不起
那么首先国家调控
对吧
那么最近也闹猪瘟也开始杀猪了
那么现在一般就现在当然还没有大规模爆发了对不对因为还没有明确的说这个玩意儿就ASB能够租传人
没有就是说
大家对他的这个危害性
现在还没有意识到
就是这个问题
而且呢
现在目前疫情处置的这个手段
还是比较及时的
没有引发大规模的这个扩散
对不对
所以呢
现在怎么说疫情驱动的事件
我们比如说我们以龙头板块为主
比如说中木
你看没有什么没有什么移动
对不对
没有什么移动
我们就说了
你看去年600678的时候是怎么走的
他之前是有一个这么个过程
看到了吧
他会是有一个这样的过程
当时呢
他是不显山不落水的
就是这样一种状态
盘在下面不动的
看到了吧
然后突然之间
那个新冠就来了
就直接就这么上去
你看
那你问我到底选什么
这种类型的好
因为你现在做的这个是事件驱动型的
并没有落地
就这个事情还没有
没有操作
没有消息
就可能还在一个
什么征服阶段
懂了吗
那么你其实你要干的事情是什么
是他突破的那一刹那进去就可以了
而不是在这个地方去潜伏他
没有必要
因为首先你不知道他什么时候来啊
什么时候大规模的控制不住了
就来了
那你就在他起量的那一瞬间跟进去就可以了
懂吗
你以这个作为标准就好了
以这个为标准
就找这样的形态
反正一共也就十几个股票
对不对
肉药啊
抗生素啊
这一种
好吧
嗯
反正呢
我们也知道中国
现在疫情在中国
想大规模扩散也很难
咱们有新冠的疫情的这个经验了
对吧
我们就比如
国家的这个疾控卫生中心
都是跟神一样的
现在啊
对不对
基本上能够掐死在什么
萌芽之中
懂了吧
当然今年还是少吃猪肉比较好
好吧
哎
就是这个意思啊
当然赚这个钱呢
你就是赚到了你给去你给有回向对吧去去菜市场买点鱼啊买点青蛙啊
买点泥鳅啊
买点甲鱼啊
是吧
买点虾啊
找河啊往里面一丢就好了
懂了吗
要放生啊
有这个钱你赚的
你懂的你知道什么意思
你怎么来的这个钱
对不对
你是发什么钱的
OK
这就是关于这个珠瘟的问题
好吧
还有问题没有
实际上已经开始了
但是我们说了
我们向国家控制的
这一块还是很强的
能不能吹话出来
不知道
那么现在四月份了
立川已经过了
那么古雨马上就要来
对不对
还有什么想问的
再说一下国内的苹果吧
目前国内空头第一名
大家都知道是谁的
稍微讲一下苹果
现在已经是没有人性了
对吧
苹果
从去年八千多
现在已经快到5000多了
看一下短短的时间
半年
30%
苹果
苹果现在处在什么周期
首先你比如说你做一个商品
你也了解它
那么苹果一共分六个周期
这边有没有中国苹果的
不知道
我给你们解释一下
苹果有六个周期
第一个周期是
这个花蕾期
苗
也就是说
你要种苹果
你先给栽树
这棵树
需要四到五年
落下去
懂了吧
然后四到五年的时候
它会结出这个包
花蕾
第二个
就是开花的时候
结花期
第三个步骤
是落果
就它会长出一种
很小的
很轻的那种小圆不隆动的东西像果实雏形但是有很多会死掉会掉下来叫落果这是第三个周期第四个周期就是膨胀期
膨胀期
就是这个果子会慢慢的长大
从绿色慢慢的开始变颜色
吸收阳光
吸收养分
那么这个时间就要去施肥了
懂了吗
那么落果期在什么时候出现
就是不是
开花的时间是在每年的四月份
记住啊
这是现在
现在就是苹果开花的时候
懂了吧
到6月份开始就要开始什么
落果了
秋天的时候成熟
就是我们后面说的那个成熟期
在秋天
经过六七八
这三个月份
9月份
八九月份就要出来了
所以按照现在苹果的趋势
根据基本面的这个情况
大家就知道了
他最后供应的高差还没有来
苹果啊
就它什么时候是下市就上市的
应该是在今年的八九月份
大批量会上来
当然现在很多农民开始砍树了
为什么不中了
因为你现在的价格
你要是去卖的话亏死
首先把把手砍了
换其他的这个植物去了
它不中了
可能原来是果园
现在把苹果手砍掉
开始种桃子
苹果今年涨不涨价
我不知道
但是桃子可能会涨价
懂了吗
那么就是这样的
什么东西赚钱种什么
那么这个都赔的跟狗一样了
不种了
懂了没有
但是你们会发现一个问题
就是为什么我吃的苹果
我们现在吃的苹果没有降价的
知道原因吗
对吧
你看
如果说去年一只苹果是十块钱的话
那么现在应该是七块钱的苹果
一斤对吧
但是你去
你现在去超市也好
去水果店
你感觉苹果没有跌
评论
这个是出什么问题了
明明说
这个现货价格也好
期货价格也好再跌吧
为什么水果店里卖的苹果
不跌反涨呢
中间商是吧
因为很简单
水果店的老板要交房租
对吧
对不是
房租涨了呀
懂了没有
跟跟苹果便宜不便宜没关系
房租涨到速度
就房租涨到速度已经超过了
苹果跌到速度了
所以他没办法
啊
但是
有人要吃
对不对
然后呢
我是想什么呢
因为像这个东西
它不可能一直跌下去
它毕竟
苹果嘛
对吧
还是要吃的
所以这个需求
懂不
这个需求没办法
这需求是固定的
反正我
我们在座的各位
反正从小到大
你说我从来不是苹果的
没有吧
都吃过的
对吧
就吃多少的
所以说它也不可能一直跌下去
懂了没有
所以我在想呢
到今年最旺季的时候啊
等农民把树砍的差不多了
没人中了
这个时候考虑一下苹果的什么
多担机会
对不对
其实这个就像当时的原油一样嘛
等到
等到那个苹果的价格比那个装苹果的宽多便宜的时候
大家买不买苹果
是不是
就你回忆一下去年原油是怎么走的
那不就说了吗
这个东西懂了吗
他怎么跌
他还是值钱的
他还是值点钱的
懂不
这比如说我现在运
运一车苹果从这个山东
烟台拉到这个广州
或者拉到上海
我把这个苹果卖掉
如果都赶不上我的运费的时候
这个时候苹果就低估了
明白了打个音
就是我跑一次
从烟台跑上海
路费可能要花个三四千
对吧
还交过路费
但是我把这一车苹果卖掉
我都赚不到这个钱的时候
当所有人都觉得苹果不好
没人去种的时候
需求还在
突然之间
怎么评工买不到
这个时候
记住
你看以前的鸡蛋也是这么干的
对吧
鸡蛋已经被爆炒过好几次了
涨了下去
暴跌再回来
包括糖啊大蒜都是这样来的
对不对
但是这个东西呢
不能做现货
只能做期货
因为你买现货
你放不了几个月就坏了
所以只能通过期货去实现这个
套利的机会
对不对
所以呢
我想呢
我们9月份之后啊
再看一下国内的苹果价格啊先只是做一个这个做个标记啊反正您也看到了啊这是我们国内苹果的价格最高的话是从一万多
一万两千五
现在是
五千多啊
看到了吧
最高价格
一百一万多啊
一万两千五
现在是五千
五千五
一百一半还要多
对吧
你腰斩一半就六千多
他不止
他腰斩一半还要多
那么累计跌幅
从最高点开始算
苹果都跌成狗了
超过50%了
对吧
我跟大家说过
你看现在已经54%了
对不对
再往下来
跌个什么80% 90%
当然越低越好了
对不对
只要它是一个东西
它不可能归零的
它不像股票
股票可能退市归零了
它再便宜
96.99%
我不相信苹果说一毛钱一金
那不现实的事情
对不对
所以现在我就等它继续往下杀
懂了吗
继续往下杀
最好后面是无量的阴电
就一直往下走
然后我们再找机会
这个是放在后面的事情上去
好吧
就稍微插一句
当然现在苹果你肯定不能做多的
对吧
现在不行
现在刚刚开花的时候
现在花累期
开花期
六月份之后开始长果子
知道吧
开始结果了
西游记里面说三千年一开花
三千年一结果
再过三千年才可以吃
吃一颗就与天地同寿了
对吧
当然那个西奇东西
那肯定很贵
苹果这个东西烂大街了
对吧
都是
其实在西方处理这种情况
比如说牛奶便宜了
他们会干嘛
比如说美国人
牛奶跌的不赚钱
他就会把牛奶倒掉
对吧
不卖
就我不给你们
我把它倒掉
我也把这个牛奶又借的价格卖出去
是不是这样
后面苹果估计也是这么处理的
知道吧我前面倒掉我也不弄那么现在农民就是我前面把树砍了我我钱烂到地里面我也不买毛病啊还不够运营费的呢对吧
没意思啊
对的你看啊
国内有一家
不是国内啊
你看这个
看到了吧
这个品牌大家都喝过没有
会员果汁
听说过的请打个六
会员嘛
对吧
你看他的股价
你就明白了
果汁嘛
滚来了
你看这果汁怎么走的
对吧
你懂的呀
那你就玩此消彼长的嘛
懂吗
一般就苹果汁
还有椰奶
还有橙汁
这些啊
好了
嗯这个是
这是那个是什么
就直播以外的事情啊
你给我画的是什么
对好
那他找到找到一个复盘看到了
对吧
漂亮吗
漂亮不
那我们我们给他
给他鼓个掌啊
他去找他他他用功了
看到吧
那么
4号线比523都要低
对不对
一号线是阳线
那么零号线走空
第一目标位
这
对吧
看到了吗
他表扬一下
人家学的就很好了
你们呢
经典案例
MO
是MO找的
看懂了没有
哪里
这个地方是第一
就这根向引线的低点
就是第一个目标位置你看到他在这他会有个拦截看到没有他往上反弹了一下在这个地方然后再下来又找了一个是吧
下面图看不见啊
下面图看不到
挡住了
这是什么图
你不用管他
你让他找案例就行了吗
对不对
把形态识别出来
看到了没有
这里就是了
对的不是所有都成功的
你要看位置
对吧
高盈亏比吗
比如说高盈亏比的话
我们胜率有50%加就够了
你算比账
比如说你每次的盈亏比是5比1
你胜率在50%
请问你赚不赚钱
想一想
比如说你这个系统的胜率在50%
但是你的盈亏比是1比5
请问你能赚钱吗
能不能
很高了
对啊
你亏就亏100
赚就赚500吗
50%的概率
一半对一半错
你实际上可以赚钱的
懂了
但是你也不要做习惯了
你都不要做习惯
你天天就去找这种形态
赚大钱还可以靠什么
大趋势
好吧
还有什么想问的
没有了吧
那么黄金这边插一嘴啊
明天
就今天这根线的糕点不知道在哪里
但是明天如果他还敢过这个糕点
你要选择加仓
就是你在之前有这个地方有多单的人
记住了没有
有底仓的情况下面
明天突破今天的最高价还可以加
但是这个加仓的方法是顺势加仓的
倒进这套啊
是这样加的啊
反正加的
是这样的
比如说你今天开一手
明天开0.5
懂了吧
越往上越小才会顺势加仓
就是这个高点
假设今天收盘了
明天再次盘中突破
就去加仓
清楚了吗
因为你有利润在
也就明天可以加
记住了
再上去就没有机会加仓了
因为这个点如果再突破
就面临的紧线
这个双底就要走出来了
对吗
双帝以上
就这根井线上方
你就不要去加仓了
这个任务就交给那些后知后觉的人进场就可以了
你不要在这个位置
在去加什么东西了
懂了吗
你就不要去当抬轿子的人了
自己搭轿子
自己还要抬轿子
那就没有什么意思
就这里上去交给什么
跟风盘就行了
知道了吧
好
明天还有一
就如果说今天直接突破
那你明天不要加了啊
所以他今天晚上直接
如果把这个高点突破了
今天明天就不要去加
如果他明天
今天没有突破这个点
明天突破今天的高点
是可以加一个的
小仓位再加一下
有分使劲翻
突破以后就跟你没什么关系了啊
你就拿着就完事了
懂了吗
那么理论高度是
目前短线来说是1764
第一目标位置
短线的
这波反弹的中线目标是1849
再往上看一集
就是1849
好吧
这个星期我们反正也不看太多
就是这两个位置
懂了吗
后面再说了
就是说你非要让我说一个范围
我就跟你说这两个数字
你自己记好就完事了
好吧
那么如果说你是抓拐点的
那么按照周线的腾前通道
明天就要跑了
听得懂没
明天你就要止盈了啊
我跟你们说清楚啊
不是你要是按照天图上去做的这个
你是不是明天要走了
来看一下
你要是天图上
是不是达到这根白线
突破这根白线你就要跑了
止盈了吗
懂了没那在这个位置现在唐签的上线的位置是在1755
这里
1755就是你的
天土抓拐点的指引位置
懂吗
好了
那你这个点跑还是不跑
你自己看
我不发表什么意见
懂了没有
我也不会给你什么意见
你自己看着办
好了
今天就到这儿
好吧
今天就到这儿了啊
好
各位辛苦了
A50
A50怎么了
A50还行啊
只要美股不说大问题就行
对吧
今天标普可能又创新高了啊
没事
A股慢一点没关系的
好吧
反正我不是说了吗
再过两个月建党一百周年
这个时候你说大盘跌破三千年
往两千五的地方走
政治五
对吧
有哪个有哪个不想活的站出来试试
对不对
你要跌也是等到建党节过后
对吧
开完会
不是我们建党庆祝一百周年了
那谁在这个野骨眼上犯政治错误
那吃不了都得走
对不对
记住
土地是党的
对吧
权力也是党的
我们刚才我们的股市也是党的吗
不是党国家的
对不对
但是我们国家是谁领导的
是党领导的国家
记住了没有
党领导的国家
对吧
一切
老说了算吧
对吧
好吧
还有再插一个话
那么美国罗斯福航母编队已经进入到中国南海了
对吧
紧跟着今天
昨天中国的第三艘自主研发的航母
山东舰下水
看到这个新闻了吗
别着急
今天下午
我们的辽宁舰带着编队到台湾海峡去了
今天我们两个动作啊
第一个山东号公布下水了对吧啊完全公开了两年后带着一帮小弟现在奔赴台湾在台湾周边海域巡逻是不是
那么这个意味着
你看
美国把罗斯福航母编队
派到我们南海来
我们马上紧跟着
我们派到台湾去了
而且我再告诉你
我还有一艘
对不对
那么山东舰一共用了几年
五年
就是从第一艘瓦莱安格开始改变
然后到第二艘
对不对
第二艘到现在只花了五年时间
我们就自主研发第三艘航母了
当然现在有人说常规动力的
对吧
不是核动力航母
还不算最先进的
你错了
中国不需要找核动力航母
中国就要很多常规动力就可以了
为什么
首先我们是
我们的国家不是搞侵略的
记住啊
中国所有的武器
包括我们东风
大家注意啊
东风系列导弹
它是防御性武器
记住一定要记住这两个字
防御性武器
当然外面解释
那么东风太狠来的
知道那的
不
我们国家目前研发的所有武器的目的只有一个
保家卫国
同意吧
好
所以我们的航母也是一个道理
我们航母反正我们也不出去欺负人
我们的目的是保家卫国
守护我五国领海就可以了
所以你核动力浪费钱吗
有这个钱
还不如都搞几个
从未动力的
对不对
懂了吗
因为我又不出去了
我也不会像你们美国
没事在那边
大西洋
北冰洋
这边巡逻
咱们不需要这么大的地方
对吧
咱们守好自己第一岛链就好了
对不对
所以我觉得这个思路是对的
不用去搞什么核动力
我们以数量取胜
实在不行
打到最后了
对吧
发装机开
给你航母对撞也行吗
反正我们便宜吧
是不是
我们便宜吧
谁怕谁
两个航母对撞好了
打到最后没有子弹了
没有武器了
那就撞
对不对
但是我生产力
我爆兵进啊
你在我家海域
我如果我爆兵的话
我说实话
现在中国是不想去造
如果现在比如说打三战了
中国一旦爆兵
美国人看不懂
你信不信
就是我们真发狠劲要去就是你打我意思我照不说出来中国有这个能力的对不对在关键时候它就会来但是现在我们没有
没有这个需要
所以一切都是防御性的
但是我们说
从这个事件背后
能够感受到什么
比如说中国强大了
是吧
中国想跟美国搬手腕了
对不对
不是
不是我们强大了
是美国弱了
要这么去理解这个问题
我们没有变过
我们光刻机被卡脖子了
对不对
我们各种測室产权都被卡脖子了
芯片没有
杀没有
操作系统也没有
我们是被卡脖子的一方
大家记住了
我们脖子越凶
就说明你们那边越弱
因为只有弱者才会去干什么
去扼杀别人
真的强的不怕你
你来追我呀
对不对
你看当年美苏竞赛的时候
你来追我呀
我把那个什么什么
送到月球上去了
紧跟着
怕我也上去了
紧跟着你那么清淡来
我来个大意外
对不对
那个时候公平竞争
那个时候叫角竹
现在不叫角竹
现在叫什么
叫巧脖子
对吧
所以呢我们说
中国还是那个中国
美国可能就变了
对吧
美国现在急了呀
生怕中国怎么样
所以你看
他现在亚太战略
对不对
以前你看
以前特朗普是单挑的
单挑中国
现在不是
他群殴
他拉拢很多小弟
对吧
英国啊
欧盟啊
日本啊
反正
战略合作伙伴
以前特朗普一个人
打一个中国
对不对
现在拜登是
组团来的
但是
没什么用
中国还挺好
对吧
稍微我们提一下中国的事情
所以在
建党之际
我们要有政治觉悟
为我们是一个中国人感到骄傲
好吗
当然我们不谈超越美国
我们只求
是吗
别人不欺负我们就好了
对不对
答题还需支撑印
好了
那么今天咱们的直播就到这
祝各位交易生
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕